[Applause]
i have our cup we are cervini angels oh
my god gosh i don't have my cup rachel
i'm such a goober oh it's it's somewhere
i'll i'll i'll find it maybe in the
commercial break guess what
no i i don't mean to be creepy but this
is what i was on my couch with and then
eventually in bed with i couldn't put it
down
and i just read it front to back it's
all dog-eared and what i loved about
this cookbook reading it last night
rachel was how much i feel like no one
is like you you talk about grabbing a
handful as a measurement
taking the stress out
i think you're one of the most
incredibly liberating and and
encouraging people to be freer in the
kitchen
you know i never thought i would write a
cookbook or be on television ever so
when i approached writing it was always
from the point of view of
the home cook not
of the chef or professional or aspiring
to be anything other than
hungry and making dinner
i still write in the same manner 26 uh
books later and now they're more like
memoir mashups i just finished
my 27th and delivered it in december it
will be out next september
and it's it's mostly essays and some
recipes but i still write in the same
manner that i did
all those years ago
you have had such an incredible journey
and you have accomplished so much in
your life and i was wondering if you
would take a trip down memory lane with
me and look at some milestones and
memories i'm good with anything for you
buddy okay let's take a look at rachel
through the year
oh my gosh all right 1968 rachel was
born on august 25th what are some of
your very first memories uh when you
were a kid my very first memory is my
mom
uh
in the kitchen
at the restaurant our our restaurant was
called the carvery and we were out in uh
cape cod and i remember being on my
mom's hip
and she was fighting with a purveyor on
the phone while she was heating up all
of the griddles and grills and cooktops
and you know she was turning everything
on in the restaurant and she went to
hang up the phone she put me down
and i put my hand up
to grab a spatula
and i grilled my entire thumb
from here to here
to the stove top
today it's a darker color than the rest
of my hand
and that is literally my first memory in
life griddling myself so it's kind of a
harry potter-ish thing you know what i
mean it's like
that certainly
said what i was born to be and what what
i've done with the whole rest of my 52
years i
love that story so much let's see which
year we're going to next
oh gosh
1982 you started working as a bus girl
dishwasher and fountain girl what did
those jobs teach you and prepare you for
the years to come
dish machine operator not a very
glamorous life
a dmo i was the dmo
and when i got promoted to the fountain
i thought my life would be amazing
it was like cinderella like it was like
being a prom queen
to go to the fountain and get to wear a
dress
and
waitress shoes instead of being at this
120 degree dish machine
buried in 3 000 dishes that smell like
you know eggs and hamburgers it was just
so exciting
and then um i realized that i was too
short to scoop the ice cream and there
was a little faucet that would clean the
scoops so there was a constant stream
of leftover ice cream on the side of the
ice cream cooler so when i push myself
up and throw myself curl myself into the
ice cream cooler to get the ice cream
i ended up with a line of melted
sour every flavor
that howard johnson served of ice cream
across my boobs
so i became the girl with
the ice cream boobs not only
was it worse than me at the dish machine
but i was out in public and i had a line
across
myself and i smelled so
thanks for bringing up some fun times
we said last night it was like you had
two scoops
and
double yes i also didn't anticipate
rachel that i would be dressed like a
soda jerk today so this is perfect all
right let's see what's next you still
are i
really i mean okay 1985
you started your first business called
delicious liaisons while you were in
high school what was it
um dangerous liaisons was a big movie a
big big stage production big movie and
great great book and whatever
so i thought delicious liaisons what a
fun name
so i just for fun i made a fake catalog
of delicious liaisons gift baskets for
people
and i showed it to my mother and she
thought it was so delightful she took it
down to the print shop
and she had a bunch of these made up
so i just started handing them out to
random people at the grocery store at
the pizza place in my class give this to
your mom your dad and i started making
uh baskets for sale
it was just really an art project but
well and
you know the the origin story of a
pioneer next we are going to the year
1997 you launched 30 minute meals
oh my gosh with local news station
wrgb
oh w.r.j
bay and you were in upstate new york
what was the initial
launch like my my boss who's one of my
best friends to this day donna carnevale
we are
her her birthday's this week by the way
happy birthday don happy birthday yeah
we are we are super dear friends to this
day
donna said people love your food
why don't you just teach the class we we
had an idea to sell cooking classes
and we we made the mistake as two real
savvy business ladies
to
underprice the classes so when we went
to ask chefs to teach the classes that
we were selling so that we could sell
more groceries
uh we would have lost money rather than
made
so donna said well you just teach the
class i said but john i'm not a chef she
said who cares everybody likes her food
they buy it prepared in the case
so you teach them
so the news uh station wrgb the world's
first news station because it's the home
of
uh
ge general electric
it was literally the world's first
television station they came to do
a piece on us
and our little class
and it became a weekly segment and i
would go to people's homes and fire
houses and police stations and i would
teach
literally anybody who would let us in
how to make a 30-minute meal
that's that it was a a weird
circumstance well
i don't care about anyone's business
prowess because you can't deny the power
of 30-minute meals that's a
billion-dollar idea it's so good
[Music]
you